how you were able to go from being
bankrupt in your 20s to owning
everything we started with nothing I
went and got my degree in real estate
went through a couple jobs and then I
quickly started buying real estate and I
got rich I had a million dollar net
worth at 24 years old our bank got sold
to another bank and some guy looks down
and said hey there's a 24 year old kid I
was just a million bucks let's limit
this relationship which is Banker talk
for ruin his life so we had 2 million we
had to come up with and 120 and it's all
in real estate so it started a crash
that I couldn't recover from and we
spent the next two and a half years
losing everything we owned being sued
and foreclosed on and finally with a
brand new baby and a toddler and our
marriage Hanging On by a thread without
bankruptcy in September of 88. I started
studying what the Bible says about money
which was just common sense get out of
debt live on less than you make live on
a budget have a plan and I start doing
this stuff and that evolved into people
asking me okay how are you recovering
from your bankruptcy and fast forward
all of that to this massive thing